All right guys, so here is example number two
for breaker block entries.
So you can see we have higher high, higher low
and higher high.
And then we have a
a market structure shift right here.
So normally what you would do is you would take your entry
from this favorite gap or this favorite gap.
But if you are using the breaker block entry model,
your breaker block is right here,
which is the last candle before the move to the upside.
And after that you have a shift in market structure.
So you see this move, right?
There was no bearish candle around here, okay?
If there was a bearish,
let's assume that this candle was bearish, right?
And then you had a,
so I would consider then this as market structure shift.
And then I would consider that candle as my breaker
because apparently that was the last bearish candle
or last candle or you could say high, high, high low,
last high low and then we had higher high
and then market shift.
So I hope you get what I'm trying to explain.
So, but in this case, this was the last candle, right?
Or sometimes what I would do is it's sometimes
a good practice to mark out the bearish candle
instead of the bullish candle and vice versa.
So if you are looking for a long position,
you should mark out the bullish candle
instead of the bearish candle.
But it's not gonna affect that much.
You can take your entry from the last candle, okay?
Or the, yeah.
So you can see if I drag this along,
we had market structure shift
and what was really nice about this breaker block
is that we had fair value gap here as well.
Now that is when breaker blocks become very, very,
I would say powerful, okay?
So keep that in mind that yeah,
you can use breakers as their own without fair value gap,
but if there's fair value gap,
then that entry is gonna be perfect.
So I'm gonna explain another thing.
A lot of people say that they missed their entries
whenever they tried to enter from the extreme fair value gap.
If you are, if you don't wanna miss, you know,
the trades, what you can do is right
when you have a market structure shift,
you can take your entry from the very recent fair value gap,
okay?
Instead of taking your entry from the extreme,
you can take your entry from the very first,
but there's a catch, okay?
You need to secure your stop loss.
So let's say if fries goes back to the extreme fair value gap,
you do not lose, okay?
You do not wanna give your money to the markets,
even though your analysis are right.
So this is the only way, guys.
If you want me to tell you guys to put your stop here,
yeah, of course you can, but you're gonna lose, okay?
And even though your analysis are going to be perfect,
a price can stop you up because it needs to fill
and balance the prices up there.
So keep your stop maybe here or maybe here,
and kaboom, okay?
Perfect.
So yeah, guys, I really hope that the,
you know, I really hope that you guys
have a clear knowledge about breaker blocks now.
It's simply the last candle.
So you have, so see, I'll try to explain it once again.
If Justin cares if anyone did understand.
So you have higher high, higher low, higher high.
Right?
So the last candle of the higher low
is gonna be your breaker block.
And you must get a market structure shift
after this new high is created, right?
And when you have market structure shift,
then that breaker block becomes valid.
However, if you had, let's say, higher high, higher low,
higher high, it's small, higher low,
and then higher high, and then market structure shift,
then that last candle would be your breaker.
So yeah, let's move on to the next videos.